Yeah, so for situations like this when we go downhill, it's easy to take the second gear,
clutch it in,
loose the brake and then we have the button underneath the clutch pedal where we also can
brake. Not only with the brake pedal and the brake, also with the button under the clutch,
it's also a brake. And it doesn't shut the engine while we do that? No, only when you stay,
it shuts off. Ah yeah. Now it only closed the exhaust pipe and so we have not enough power to run
really fast. Okay.
What's this road on the left? Is it for fire? This is, I think, one of the fire lanes. I will do and
check this next week complete with Jeremy. He will show me all the entrance and outlet areas
where we can go or not. And then we make a recording of all the roads. So for the future that everybody
knows when we have a fire maybe near the dome or something like that, where is the best way to go
easily without big damages. Right.
Perhaps next time we arrange the ways. Yeah, that is one thing for the next winter season to
prepare all the roads that we can go easily without damaging. Nothing. Yeah. You see now I must turn
backwards because they have not enough space here of the oak tree.
It's always to be safe. Don't worry about the truck cannot fall on the side or normal things.
So we have no mountains here where it's so dangerous that we can't drive. Okay.
So it's always safe, yeah? Yes. This machine is built for riding off-road. Right.
So when we have a really emergency, we are driving much faster than now.
But now it's only for show you everything. In the next weeks and months we try also to drive.
Everybody can learn to drive this truck.
So important when we arrive at the place where we will fire fighting,
handbrake, gear out.
Now we can go out. And we leave it on. Yes, for sure. We need the engine for the pump.
Then the first thing is connect this one. This is now connected. Open this.
Steph, take the hose.
Okay. Now we connect the hose to here. We need the fire gun, the small one.
Yeah, that's a small one.
So we connect this.
Here Steph, and you follow me please.
Now we must go back inside the cabin. Maybe you go on the other side on the front seat.
So important to start the pump. Push the clutch. Hold it.
Then we have here two buttons, the orange and the black one.
When you push the orange one, you see there is a light. And then go clutching in.
So now we need the throttle. Now we push it on the right side because the throttle goes up.
And you can see here in between 5 and 15,000 rpm we have the right throttle. Now you can see.
Okay, now we have a good throttle. Now we go outside and start the work.
It means 10. 10 rpm, yeah?
Yeah, it depends on the attentive power we want to spray. That I will show you in the next weeks also.
We start now with not the full power because when we do the full power, it's really strong to hold.
And for training now, because it's for all of you the first time,
no, it's better to do it not with full throttle. Okay, so when we go out, we start the...
So now the pump is on. Now we open the tap.
Now we open the tap and you see now water is coming.
Step all the small trees first, wait, make it off, go out.
Something to explain. Here it's a tap to open and close. Yeah, now it opens, now it closes.
When you open it, you can make it like this. Yeah, yeah, so now it's good for a fresh...
Well, now this is full power and here we have a wheel where we can put the level down or up.
Now it's only 20 liters per minute and it goes up to 200. 200 liters per minute.
So we use the smaller amount and then we can water the new olive trees.
Yeah, that was a plan because Jeremy asked me when we start fighting if we can go here to water the plants.
Multitasking. Yes, so now you can stop the video.
And we're gonna water the plants with Mike the gardener. Yeah.
Now you see now the pressure is that you can touch it when you put it on full power.
Yeah, this is already interesting. Yeah, this when you have something burned like a car or
a tree, you can work with that. When you have the whole area is burning, then you take this.
Let me show. You take it this under your arm and then you go like this.
Yeah, because you can spray a bigger...
Show us the technique, Mike. Show us the underarm. Yeah, yeah.
So when you have the whole area, the grass is burning, you use it like that.
Yeah, because... White, white, yeah. Then you have a bigger amount of water.
Yeah. And a bigger square meter. So a wide sprinkle, yeah?
Yeah, wide sprinkle. When you have something like a tree or a car or a house start burning,
then you do it with this because you can fight directly on the fire point.
So now I put it down. Now you can record and he can try.
Yeah. Now it's on the lowest level, but be careful. So what's the holding technique?
Which is your strongest hands, the right one? Right hand, yeah.
And push the right hand underneath and then with this you open and close.
This one, yeah?
So don't worry because it's not so much power. Okay, hold it strong here also.
See what happened? Yeah. And that is only the small gun. The big one is much more power.
You got to use your core.
Yeah. And then you go a little bit down because to train it's better to have not so much pressure.
Yeah. Yeah, also this one. This is also a new one, right? Got you.
All of trees. I want to try more. Not now. Next week.
Yeah, yeah. Because you are a strong guy like him. This is wide. Look this. And this is focused.
And now the thing is now the pump from the truck is not on full power.
And this is the close, yeah? No. Yeah, yeah, you can close. So when we put the power up,
then it's much more power than that. What's the maximum of this right now?
Yeah. Now you have 40 liters per hour and the pressure is, wait, let me see.
This is the RPM. 15,000. This is the pressure from the outlet. A little bit more than 25 bar.